what is that
it's a dead end
up there mortal is out of here
we're facing the greatest evil the world
has ever known she's executing our
people this is unlike anything we've
ever seen
[Music]
what's trying to kill us this time
pretty much everything
magic is on a whole other level
we're outmatched
how are we gonna defeat them
I know what to do I can ask coaches five
questions and then they go back to being
dead
maybe I'm not saying it
yuck wonderful
were you killing battle yes great four
more questions right yes no no no that
was that wasn't for you did that count
as a question yes
damn it
only answer when I talk to you okay why
did you say Okay at the end of that I
didn't
fantastic where's the shovel